the scale bound thing the only way I can
realistically see that happening in the
end is if there's like an agreement that
they buy Platinum yeah I just I like
this I just I find it hard to imagine
Microsoft nothing this man is shooting
a loop Wolf
Part of me feels like if they
if they didn't have to to juggle so many
projects we would see a different
Platinum I'm not a big Platinum fan but
I do think that if there was a
conversation where Microsoft talked
about buying Platinum Games and one of
the conditions was from Platinum is we
really want to finish scalebound and
Microsoft agree to that I do think you
would see probably one of Xbox's best
studio
they don't have to make 10 15 games
anymore they can make one or two